il y a notre prénom féminin qui avait
posé problème c'était Aurélie là tu as
eu des soucis avec ça des soucis oui et
non après le succès il a il a très bien
fonctionné après je pense il a cartonné
c'était un été 2011 sorti le titre que
tout le monde connaît la Aurélie qui
traite un sujet compliqué celui de
l'avortement il raconte l'histoire d'une
jeune fille qui tombe enceinte à 16 ans
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que mes
deux premiers morceaux qui ont
fonctionné c'était des chansons d'amour
et je voulais montrer que j'étais aussi
capable de traiter de certains sujets un
petit peu plus sensibles et d'accord
mais toi ça a été mal interprété tu te
rappelles ces libération il y avait dit
que c'était un véritable réquisitoire
contre l'avortement bah oui bah en fait
le truc c'est que moi j'écris mes
propres textes je suis auteur et je
m'inspire vraiment de la vie de tous les
jours et moi je me rappelle qu'à
l'époque dans mon lycée il y en avait
deux ou trois des Aurélie et ça m'avait
marqué je regrette pas puisque
aujourd'hui c'est l'une des chansons
qu'on me demande le plus
jeune fille qui veut qui est enceinte et
qui veut garder son enfant et tout le
monde
c'est l'histoire